in this video we're going to explain the
rules of John Wick and the Continental
the mysterious hotel that serves as a
neutral ground for the Assassins of the
high table underworld so grab your gold
coins and let's get started the
Continental is a chain of hotels around
the world that cater exclusively to
members of the underworld they offer a
variety of services such as Weapons
Medical Care information and even
tailoring but the most important feature
of the Continental is that it's a safe
haven for Assassins no one is allowed to
conduct any business which means no
killing on the hotel grounds this rule
is enforced by the managers of each
Continental Branch who have the
authority to revoke anyone's membership
if they break it the Continental grounds
aren't limited to the hotel itself
either they also include any property
owned by or affiliated with the hotel
such as restaurants bars theaters
museums and even Parks the boundaries of
the grounds are marked by gold coins
embedded in the pavement or walls if you
see a coin you know you're on neutral
territory the Continental grounds are
sacred and inviolable even the high
table the supreme authority of the
underworld can't override them the only
exception is if a manager of a
Continental brand decides to
de-consecrate it which means to remove
the protection and status as a neutral
zone this is what happens in John Wick
chapter 3 Parabellum when Winston the
manager of the New York Continental
declares it deconsecrated in order to
help John Wick fight against the high
table's forces the managers are the ones
who run each Continental branch and
enforce its rules they're respected and
feared by everyone in the Underworld as
they have the power to Grant or deny
access to the hotel and its services
they also have connections and influence
with other factions and organizations in
the Underworld such as the Bowery King
the director and the adjudicator the
managers are loyal to the continental
and its rules above all else they don't
take sides or interfere with anyone's
business unless it involves breaking the
hotel's rules if someone violates the
rules or challenges their Authority they
will face severe consequences such as
being excommunicated or even killed the
managers aren't above the law however
they're still subject to the high tables
oversight and judgment if they fail to
uphold their duties or betray their
allegiance they'll be punished
accordingly this is what happens to
Winston and John Wick chapter 3
Parabellum when he helps John Wick
escape from his excomication and defies
the high table's orders he is stripped
of his managerial status and Marked for
Death by the adjudicator the tailors are
one of the many specialized service
providers that cater to the Assassins at
the Continental they're experts in
crafting suits that are not only stylish
and elegant but also bulletproof and
very functional they can customize any
suit to fit any occasion whether it's a
formal event or a gunfight the tailors
use a special fabric called tactical
weave which is made from bullet
resistant fibers that can stop most
handgun rounds and some rifle rounds the
fabric is also breathable and flexible
allowing for mobility and comfort the
tailors can also add various features to
the suits such as hidden Pockets
holsters knives grenades or even armor
plates the markers are metal tokens that
serve as a record of the Blood Oath
between two parties in the Underworld
they're used when one party asks a
significant favor from another party and
the other party agrees to Grant it in
exchange for anything they want in
return at any time the person who owes
the favor leaves a bloody thumbprint on
one side of the marker while the party
who grants the favor keeps the marker
and presents it to the other party when
they want to collect their debt the
markers are sacred and they can't be
refused ignored or broken anyone who
violates a marker will face dire
consequences the only way to close a
marker is to fulfill the debt or have
both parties agree to nullify it the
markers aren't limited by time place or
circumstance they can be called in at
any moment for any reason no matter how
inconvenient or dangerous it may be for
the debtor the Creditor can also ask for
anything they want no matter how
unreasonable or immoral it may be for
the debtor these markers are not common
they're reserved for extreme situations
and rare occasions they're also not
transferable they can only be used by
the original parties involved The Only
Exception is if one of the parties dies
in which case their air or successor can
inherit the marker and use it as they
see fit the markers are first introduced
in John Wick chapter 2 when Santino
d'antonio uses a marker to force John
Wick to assassinate his sister who is a
member of the high table Jon reluctantly
agrees but then kills Santino for
betraying him and breaking the
Continental rules this leads to John's
excommunication and bounty in John Wick
chapter 3 Parabellum the gold coins are
the currency of the underworld they're
used to pay for goods in and services
provided by anyone who works under the
high table such as assassins arms
dealers doctors cleaners informants and
so on they're also used to show respect
and gratitude to anyone who helps or
favors someone in the Underworld the
gold coins are not based on monetary
value they're based on social value they
represent the Commerce of relationships
a social contract in which both parties
agree to partake they also represent
access membership and Trust in the
Underworld the gold coins are not easy
to obtain they're earned through hard
work and skill they're also not easy to
spend they're saved for important
occasions and transactions so they're
not wasted on trivial things or
frivolous Pleasures the high table is
the supreme authority of the underworld
it's a council of 12 powerful crime
Lords who rule over their respective
territories and factories around the
world they set and enforce the rules
that govern all aspects of life and
death in the Underworld they also
oversee and regulate all activities and
transactions that take place under their
jurisdiction the high table is respected
and feared by everyone in the Underworld
as they have the power to Grant or deny
favors privileges resources and
protection to anyone who works under
them you also have the power to punish
or reward anyone who obeys or disobeys
them they don't care about loyalty honor
or Justice they only care about order
balance and profit but the high table is
not Invincible or infallible they have
enemies and Rivals who seek to overthrow
them or break their rules they also have
weaknesses and flaws that can be
exploited or exposed by anyone who knows
them the adjudicator is an agent of the
high table and a representative of the
Elder the mysterious leader of the
underworld they're sent to New York to
deal with John Wick and those who aided
him after he killed Santino d'antonio on
the Continental grounds they serve as
the main antagonist of John Wick chapter
3 Parabellum the adjudicator is not a
fighter but a judge they have the power
to judge anyone who breaks the rules or
challenges the high table and to assign
punishments or rewards accordingly the
soup kitchen is a vast intelligence
Network run by the Bowery King in New
York it masquerades as a homeless
shelter and consists of many agents in
the form of homeless people it is
completely unaffiliated with the high
table until the Bowery King offers its
services to them the soup kitchen is not
a charity but a business it does not
provide food or shelter it provides info
information and data it uses access to
the city's underground tunnels and
passageways to quickly move about with
ease it also uses homing pigeons to
deliver messages in the form of
microchips or other small objects the
soup kitchen is not harmless or helpless
it's dangerous and resourceful it has
eyes and ears everywhere in the city
hiding in plain sight as Beggars
vagrants or panhandlers it has lots of
allies and enemies in various factions
and organizations in the Underworld the
old ways are the traditions and Customs
that govern the conduct and etiquette of
the assassins in the Underworld they're
based on respect honor and
professionalism they include things like
greeting each other with a nod
exchanging gold coins for services using
code names or aliases and so on the old
ways also include the dueling laws which
are the rules that apply when two
assassins decide to settle their
differences or disputes through combat
the dueling laws are as follows the duel
must be agreed upon by both parties no
one can be forced or coerced into a duel
The Duel must be fair and honorable no
cheating or interference is allowed The
Duel must be witnessed by a neutral
third party who can act as a referee or
a judge the duel must have clear terms
and conditions such as the weapons the
location the time limit and the stakes
The Duel must end when one party
surrenders dies or is incapacitated no
unnecessary violence or cruelty is
allowed the duel must be respected and
honored by both parties no grudges or
Revenge are allowed the old ways and the
drooling laws are respected and followed
by most assassins in the Underworld as
they provide a sense of order dignity
and pride they also prevent unnecessary
Bloodshed and Chaos in the Underworld
however some assassins may choose to
ignore or violate them either out of
arrogance greed or desperation this may
result in consequences such as being
shunned hunted or killed by other
assassins excommunicado is the status of
an assassin who has been expelled from
the underworld for breaking the rules it
means that they lose all access to the
continental and its services as well as
any protection or assistance from anyone
who works under the high table it also
means that they become a target for
every other assassin in the world who
can claim a bounty on their head the
excommunicado isn't permanent though it
can be reversed or lifted by the high
table or anyone who has their Authority
however this is very rare and unlikely
as it would require a very good reason
or a very high price the honor code is
the moral and ethical code that most
assassins follow in the Underworld it's
based on loyalty integrity and
compassion it includes things like
honoring one's word keeping one's
promises the for penguin's debts and
showing Mercy or kindness to those who
deserve it the undercoat isn't a rule
though it's a choice it's not enforced
or regulated by anyone but it's
self-imposed and self-regulated by each
individual last but not least don't hurt
his dog this isn't a rule it's a warning
don't hurt his dog means don't mess with
John Wick don't provoke him don't anger
him don't cross him don't do anything
that would make him come after you with
the Vengeance don't hurt his dog because
his dog is more than just a pet it's a
symbol of his love his loss and his hope
his dog is a gift from his late wife
Helen who died of a terminal illness his
dog is a reminder of his happy past when
he was retired from being an assassin
and lived peacefully with Helen don't
hurt his dog because if you do you'll
unleash the wrath of John Wick you will
awaken the Baba Yaga the legendary
assassin who once killed three men with
a pencil you have been warned
[Music]
thank you